(snaping)
(groaning)
(romantic music)
- Today we're tryin' on sexy edibles.
I like sex and I like eatin'!
- (chuckling) This is gonna be weird.
- If your mouth is gonna
be on a dick or in a vagina
or in a but, then what's wrong with candy?
- Sex is sticky enough as is.
- Let's get to strippin'
and get to lickin'!
- I'm ready, I'm hard, let's go!
- Bring forth the candy!
Candy pants!
- [Voiceover] For men!
- Ow, Katie, god!
- No, it's okay, I got it!
- Woah!
- This is a square.
- It's like a fruit roll up!
- Fruit by the six inches.
Like, ish.
- Hold on, baby, let me
put on my edible pants!
- Oh.
(leathery rustle)
You hear that?
(groans)
This isn't candy.
- These aren't pants.
- This looks like a used maxi pad.
- I think I get it, though.
- It's got these little
ties, which is kinda cute.
- Hold on honey, oh!
I broke it!
- Does it make my butt look good?
(laughing)
- How does that look?
Is that sexy?
- [Zach] Ta da!
(laughter)
- I feel pretty good about
the way it makes my body look.
- [Keith] But, apparently, I can eat it.
- I'm goin' straight
for the dick! (growling)
(growling)
- Ah, it wasn't as dramatic--
- [Voiceover] Oh no!
- Oh no!
The residue makes it look
like my dick is bleeding!
(gentle munching)
(groaning)
- (groaning) Uh!
- Oh!
- Ah, it's like sour!
- Doesn't taste like a fruit by the foot.
- Does taste like pants.
- Oh, that's not the
flavor I was expecting!
- I'm seriously gonna vomit!
- Do you think my saliva's red, now?
Yep!
- Oh, this is so bad!
- Oh, they're like stuck to my teeth.
- Huh?
- Oh, do I have to eat any more of this?
(snaps)
- Oh god, they're turning my hands red!
(crunching)
- It's very hard to eat.
- Oh, oh, it's tasting like, my pants!
- Ack!
- What are they holding on to?
What's wrong with me?
- I can't get it outta my mouth!
(retching and coughing)
- This was a huge mistake!
- (sobbing laughter)
What's it on, what's it on?
How's it doin' this?
(groaning and crying)
- I don't feel sexy anymore!
- I'm pooping a grocery bag!
- Ah!
- Is it on my teeth?
- And this is supposed
to be mixed with semen
and butt and vagina juice?
- I can't suck (chuckles)
somebody's dick like this!
I'm a monster!
(crying and laughing)
Ah!
- Yuck! (retching and chuckling)
- No!
- If this is where we're starting,
(chuckles) we're fucked!
- 'Member when it was in my butt?
- [Voiceover] Lovers candy
bra and Lover candy g-string!
- Oh, it doesn't smell good.
- It's like a puka shell
necklace for your ass.
- You know, normal strings
don't feel great up butts.
- Oh, that is a new feeling!
- You think that this
would diffuse my farts
and they would just smell like roses?
- Get over here!
- I feel like I'm pullin' this off!
- I'ma text a picture to my wife.
- Just pretend I'm a girl.
Everybody pretend I'm a girl!
- [Eugene] I feel like
this is a good thing to try
on Valentine's Day if you
want to look cute and sexy.
- Look at that!
- It's like a little abacus.
I had sex once, twice.
- Where do you eat first on this?
- We should get somebody
to eat this off'a me.
- I didn't want to have
my wife be subjected
to having to eat this,
on camera. (laughs)
- [Voiceover] (cheering) Ah yeah!
Scratch it out, scratch
it out, scratch that!
- Howdy!
- Do you know what you're
hear for? (laughing)
- No!
- Are you wearing edible
lingerie right now?
- Maybe!
- Well, unwrap your present.
(laughter)
(surprised laughter)
- [Keith] What do you think now?
- Still, yeah, still much! (chuckles)
- Do you think I look cute?
- No!
- It goes up your butt?
(hearty laughter)
- I don't even have a cute ass like that.
- You just break it off?
- No, no, no, no, no, you bite it off.
- What's your safe word?
- Faster.
- I feel like gay guys
just get to the point.
We're like wham, bam,
spit on it a little.
- [Ned] Right?
- Stick it in and do it.
- [Ned] Oh, okay.
- Where should I go first?
(screams)
(laughter)
- Alright, so, now I'm gonna fuck you up.
- What?
- Lay down, babe!
(thump and groaning)
Are you okay?
(laughing)
- Oh, I'm so nervous, now.
- Alright.
Oh, man!
- Sorry mom and everyone.
- Sorry Kiki Perez.
- Sorry Ashley Perez.
- This is for every 15 year old girl
who comments on the Try Guys videos.
- Maybe make 'em 18!
(laughter)
- Be gentle!
- Here's a dick one.
Oh my god.
(crying out and laughing)
- [Kelsey] Did I bite your dick!
- Ow, you bit my dick!
(screaming)
- Ah, (laughing)
I felt Zach's butt on my face!
- [Curly] (muffled) I can't get this one.
- Alright, just chew.
(screaming)
(candy snaps)
(laughter and crying out)
- [Eugene] Oh no!
- Okay, I'm leaving, goodbye!
- You freed my nipple, bro!
(laughing and cheering)
- Wow, okay.
It's like salty and sweet.
- My dick or the candy?
(laughter)
(relaxed sigh)
- So, we decided we'd send
Eugene out of the room
and have him play a little game called
which white guy is he tasting!
- We won't reveal the
answers until you've got
all three of 'em.
- Shit, okay.
- I'm least looking forward to Zach
because I just don't know
where there would be no hair--
(gentle whispers)
Oh my god!
- I have a honey dust powder
which smells like fuckin'
baby powder and potpourri.
- Oh, I already smell something!
What is that?
Why are you guys touching me?
Lick there?
(retching)
That was baby powder on...
um...
the white guy was Ned?
(buzzing)
It tasted like babies.
- I've got some spearmint
sensation body gel,
which is gon-- (gel squirts)
(groaning)
A nightmare on my body!
- It's gross!
It's gross, Eugene!
- Straight forward?
- Yup, yup.
(retching and coughing)
Oh no, oh no, no, no, no, no!
That was hair!
Why are you givin' me hair flavored stuff?
Zach.
(bell dings)
It had to be Zach 'cause
there was a lot of hair
and I was like flossing.
- I have a tropical flavored body paint.
Real steamy cover photo, here.
- Better not be on someone's ass or balls.
Okay.
(pouty laughter) Where am
I going, where am I going?
Which way?
Wait, okay, I don't see anything.
(retching)
Wow, whatever that was was really soft.
(laughter)
That was probably the best tasting one!
I'm gonna change my answers.
(drum roll)
That was one of the softest
things my tongue has touched!
And I know my friends
and I really hate them
'cause I think it was Ned's butt!
(bells ding)
And the first one was--
(cheering)
(triumphant music)
No, it was your nipple?
That was one of the most
terrifying experiences of my life.
But, I'm glad I did it with you guys.
- What I learned today, whatever goes down
between two consenting
adults, totally fine.
- You wanna eat anywhere else?
- I don't really wanna eat anywhere else.
- What's the point in this?
- I don't know.
(laughter)
Nothing tasted good.
Not just because it was on our dicks.
(crying out)
- Are you okay?
- Yeah, it was just, it was just the skin.
Highly arousing.
- What if you wanted to spice things up?
I could see that being fun.
(growling)
- Oh!
Maybe I wanna be Ned's wife, now.
(laughter)
- [Together] Happy Valentine's
Day from the Try Guys!
What will we try next?
- That's shaving cream.
- [Keith] Oh.
- [Zach] Oh, Ned!
Did you eat it?
(laughter)
- And I think this experience
only brought us closer.
To cumin'!
(laughing and shouting)
Yeah, Valentine's Day!